on va plus loin avec virgin hier ce
bonjour virginie on l'aura compris cette
question de la visite à kiev toujours
pas officiellement comprime confirmer
même si on a compris que l'intention
politique y était allée centrale 1 elle
est au coeur de ce déplacement oui
absolument en tout cas ce qui est clair
c'est qu'il ya une évolution dans la
position de l'elysée emmanuel macron
avait dit qu il était possible qu'ils ne
se rendent à kiev qu'il le ferait si et
seulement si il apportait des
propositions concrètes si cette visite
était véritablement utile là le contexte
est un petit peu évolué il parle d'un
contexte politique absolument qui exige
une rencontre une visite donc quand on
ne sait pas mais ça va se faire et c'est
très important pour les autorités à kiev
non seulement parce que manuel mal qu'on
est l'un des derniers dirigeants
européens à ne pas s'être rendu en
ukraine avec le chancelier olaf scholz
mais aussi parce que la france est le
président de la république sont jugées
extrêmement tiède vis-à-vis de moscou je
vous rappelle juste en deux mots qui
elle reproche à emmanuel macron de
maintenir un canal de discussion avec
moscou et plus précisément avec vladimir
poutine reproche également à emmanuel
macron d'avoir dit qu'il ne fallait pas
humilier la russie des paroles qui ont
été très mal interprétée à kiev est
d'ailleurs sur cette question de
l'humiliation le président français a
été interrogé et la réponse qu'il a
donnée et et j'assume ma position c'est
à dire que pour lui l'agresseur c'est
bien la russie de la responsabilité de
la guerre c'est cesser la russie aussi
qu'il faut ce camp sanctionné que des
sanctions ont été prises mais au nom
d'un certain réalisme il revendique le
fait que à la fin il va falloir qu'il y
ait un cessez le feu et il va falloir
qu'il y ait des négociations précisant
que l'europe sera à la table des
négociations
voilà pour ce qu on va évidemment
retenir au delà du message il ya aussi
le symbole le symbole cette image d'un
chef de l'état qui passe la nuit avec
ses troupes sur cette base le ton qui va
se rendre maintenant en moldavie elle
est importante un aujourd'hui cette
cette visite alors qu'on cesse de
répéter qu on est à un moment charnière
de la guerre ou alors la moldavie c'est
un petit peu c'est loin pour nous la
moldavie c'est un petit pays entre quand
c'est à côté d'eux
de l'ukraine moins de 3 millions
d'habitants tout petit pays qui a
accueilli huit cent mille réfugiés
quatre cent mille réfugiés par dont 80
mines sont encore là la france aide
financièrement la moldavie et pour
revenir sur 7 sur cet aspect la moldavie
aimerait être membre de l'union
européenne on le sait ça va être très
compliqué très lent le processus
d'adhésion est long et donc à cette
occasion emmanuel macron a révoqué cette
proposition de communauté politique
européenne qui a trente froid c'est
d'ailleurs l'ukraine on sait qu'il ya
trois pays la géorgie l'ukraine et la
moldavie qui voudrait être membre de
l'union européenne concrètement toujours
au nom du réalisme a priori ça va être
très difficile pour eux de rentrer dans
l'union européenne emmanuel macron il y
a quelques semaines à proposer cette
communauté politique
communauté politique alors c'est une
organisation qui n'existe pas encore qui
va être en cours d'organisation peut
aussi possiblement il a précisé que
c'était une commune d'une communauté
géographique une communauté de valeurs
et que en tout cas avec son homologue
roumain ils sont d'accord pour proposer
cela notamment à la moldavie et c'est
certainement de sakineh dont il sera
question tout à l'heure on en sera plus
évidemment dans les heures qui viennent
merci beaucoup